when you say it's more you're more
negative focused
do you find that you tend to get a more
negative response from oh yeah
definitely when you i mean that's when
you have a controversial opinion then
you all get controversial comments as
well right
like if you're always saying like shows
are trash or this is bad
do you find that
or did you find that the viewers were
more likely to be negative about things
are you saying like are they more
positive now that you've swapped to
being more positive about shows yeah
definitely definitely like like one like
i i mean maybe that could be it for the
difference you know i mean like i i
because i the reason i changed my
content wasn't because of only because
of that is because some of the content
creators that i used to watch and maybe
i watched back in the day like i kind of
noticed that man being being negative is
just not very fun and sure there are
shows that i don't get more views though
it gets more views because
and that's the tough part yeah so did
you because you know because i remember
there was always like um
like the the completionist whatever
right i don't know if you've seen his
channel no he always does like these top
tens at the end of the year top 10 worst
on top 10 best games yeah and he would
release them like back to back yeah and
always the top 10 worst would get more
views oh yeah all the time even though
they were like way lesser known titles
right people just want to know what the
worst thing is yeah i mean needle drop
does the same thing every year whereas
like the top 10 worst albums of the year
always did like twice the numbers of the
top 10 best yeah and if i mean i feel
like top 10 worst is just better
clickbait because nobody really wants to
know the top 10 best or like people are
less interested in knowing what the top
10 best is they want to know what the
trash is they know that's why i when uh
i try and be oh i try and dunk on
something i try and choose something
it's just unanimously no exactly right
which is why top 10 worst is good
because normally if it's like the worst
of the worst then then people there's
people weren't bad at night because it's
just like it's there to be clowned on
you know like i can clown on x-arm all i
want and people will [ __ ] love it
because it's hilarious yeah yeah i mean
have you seen exam you know i know you
have joe he's amazing
i love it
no it's great but like if you for
example have a controversial
opinion of a popular show or a popular
thing it's gonna get a lot of views but
i feel like in the but at what cost yeah
in the in the long term like it just it
just
makes you seem like a cynical [ __ ]
and that just hates everything i'd like
even like even if you just make one
video about one popular show but just
[ __ ] on it people are going to remember
that for years
right i don't know why but people have
such long memories you could you could
you could just make like you could spend
five years is there an example that you
have in your head yeah one video there
people to this day still think i'm like
the guy who hates sword art online even
though i literally made what two videos
on it yeah out of the thousands of
videos i've made in my career
oh yeah yeah right i mean uh
even though even though there are so
many channels i can think of that i've
done way more videos [ __ ] on sword
online and yet
i'm just known as the guy who's like oh
yeah you hate sword online right i'm
like
yeah but i'm also like all these other
things
did you really hate it online that much
would
i'll say it now i played it up for the
camera
yeah i know you [ __ ] for sure but i
thought that was pretty [ __ ] obvious
i made a vegetarian 69 video
the [ __ ] parody character i made back
in the day right so it's like obviously
and again because back then when i was a
lot smaller and i was still building on
my channel but that's what you do when
you're when you're that's what you have
to do to grow you think you have to be
this exaggerated uh and you have to hate
everything right right it so much
because like i remember youtube youtube
like reviews i guess went through this
phase where being negative was like the
cool thing well just like uh around when
i i hate everything yeah like i hate
everything nostalgia critic angry video
game nerd where she'll like andre yeah
yeah exactly really underrated it was
just like being cynical was like was
just cool you know that was that was a
cool thing to do and there was a dark
period in two years of youtube was it
2014 to 16 i wanted something like that
yeah yeah then people people i think the
audience because i i just felt like i
just got [ __ ] born of it because i'm
just like what what what's what's cool
about being angry i don't want to be i
don't want to be angry i want to be
happy
you know
wow i want a controversial
right i just i just want to talk about
things i like i don't want to i don't
like it got to the point where you just
watched you just watched content and you
could tell they were they were like
playing up the anger for the camera they
were like let's let's just nitpick and
just let's just find something that i'm
just
i can just like be angry about and make
jokes about even if i don't genuinely
feel it yeah yeah sort out online but
like i'm kidding i'm kidding well i mean
it was true and that's why i don't
really make those kinds of videos
anymore either because after a while i
just realized like there's only so much
you can do and say with that kind of
content after a while where it just
becomes like oh here's
his ex youtuber getting angry once again
about the hundredth thing that he hates
and so like all right cool
anything else you can offer to the to
the website no okay i'm just gonna stop
watching you you know like what are some
of the best fan bases in the anime
fandom that you think of because we've
talked about the trick question
three questions
they all are no
like i said i like the bl one
real fans seem so welcoming and i wish
more anime fandoms were like that yeah
i think as well like in a lot of senses
i think the the manga community but like
more so the the manga community that
delves more into like the more niche
titles yeah i feel is a lot more
welcoming because like now that a lot of
my content is a lot more in that
community i've realized that when you
mention a manga that no one else has
heard of but this one person knows that
they're like what holy [ __ ] they [ __ ]
mention my favorite manga yeah i want
more people to read this kind of you
know much like the bl community right so
it's like i feel it's again it's like
the the niche communities yeah i feel
like definitely the most welcoming the
nicest although i will say i think the
bl fandom they just don't like uh people
who like fujio bait you know people like
try and like take advantage of the whole
gay uh thing who don't actually give a
[ __ ] about like supporting anything like
lgbtq well obviously if you're just
there there are a lot of people and i
swear on take talk as well so many like
people who try to take advantage of
stuff oh yeah
that's about it but i mean that's
justified i'd say um yeah no i i
i yeah i'm sorry we're in the massive
tangent then